الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه السيد
العميد انت خبير عسكري في هذا المجال ولكن
نريد منك تفسيرا واضحا قدر الامكان وهو
كيف لك ان تفسر رجوع واشنطن الى سحب
طائرات حديثه من الشرق الاوسط
وتعويضها بطائرات قديمه
جمال قد نبحث بالصوره الكبرى عن
استراتيجيه كبرى او اعاده التموضع
العالميه التي بدات ايام الرئيس
سابق اوباما نتحدث عن جبهه
مشتعله في اوروبا
ومنظومتها الامنيه اصلا جاهزه وهو حلف
الناتو ونتحدث عن منطقه الشرق حيث يتشكل
مفهوم الردع يعني اليوم الرئيس بايدن خصص
عشره مليارات دولار لمبادره خلق الردع في
منطقه المحيط العادي فاذا نتحدث جبهتين
جبهه مشتعله جبهه يعاد تنظيمها وجبهه يعاد
التعهد فيها هذا يدل على عدم اهميه
المنطقه اليوم منطقه شرق الاوسط لاي تحد
عسكري في المراحل القادمه ولكن مع ابقاء
العديد الكافي للردع في مكان ما واذا
الشيء قد يصبح التدخل من مناطق اخرى
الايه عشره هي ليست هذه الطائره الحديثه
ولكنها موجوده الامريكي لديه سرب من
الطائرات اي 10 سرب من الطائرات اف 16
الطائرات اف 15 كتيبتان
باتريوت و30 الف جندي انا اعتقد انها قوه
قافيه لمنطقه تبدلت اولويات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فيها هلا هل ترى بان
هذا الاجراء هذا القرار هو صدر فعلا بعد
زياره الرئيس الصيني لموسكو هل فعلا ارسلت
اشارات مقلقه لو واشنطن ام ان التطورات
على الارض هي سبب هذا القرار
هي بدات منذ ايام الرئيس اوباما ما يقال
الانتقال الى منطقه الاندوبوسي فيك او
محية تلك المنطقه هذه التطورات سرعت هذه
الامور جمال زياره الرئيس تشي لرئيس
الروسي ليقول له في نهايه اللقاء نحن نغير
العالم انا وانت وهذا لم يحصل منذ 100 سنه
هذا تحول اساسي انا اعتقد اليوم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحضر الى حرب ممكنه على
جبهتين في الغرب حرب ساخنه في الشرق حرب
بارده على ان يكون منطقه شرق الاوسط هي
منطقه المرور والاستراحه اذا صح التعبير
منطقه الشرق الاوسط ستكون بارده في الفتره
المقبله هل هذا ما يفسر نقل هذه الطائرات
الحديثه من الشرق الاوسط الى مناطق اخرى
من العالم
ليس بالضروره ان تكون حاميه الى درجه
تستدعي تدخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هناك قوى متحالفه مع امريكا ومنظومات
امنيه في المنطقه قادره على التعامل مع
الاشياء التي قد تستشد امنيا في هذه
المنطقه وهذه المنطقه اصلا هي منطقه
تقريبا مستقره والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خرجت من الحرب على الارهاب ومن
الحرب ضد المنظمات الى حرب ضد القوى
الكبرى لرسم نظام عالمي جديد من هنا تراجع
اهميه المنطقه
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي متحدثا من بيروت سيد العميد
شكرا لك على الافاده